hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to stowaway now this game
first came out in 2014 actually this is
a demo that was released alongside a
Kickstarter that unfortunately didn't
get funded and I haven't heard about
this game until just now but there's a
fully functional alpha which is what
you're seeing right now navigate to the
other side of D deck find a flashlight
find a toolbox regulate the valve
pressure use the CCTV feed to view the
rooms ahead pay close attention to the
deck signs to help you navigate read
notes for information relative into your
area so what's interesting about this is
that I played another game that was like
this where you were on a boat that you
weren't supposed to be on and you were
trying desperately to get off the boat
now I can't remember what the name of it
is because it very badly what is that I
see a shimmer and shadow over there that
better be a heavy blanket blasted in the
winds and oh my god the frame rate is
very low but why it is a blanket blowing
in the winds okay I'm gonna be right
back I'm gonna change some settings a
bit okay and we're back and I don't know
if there's gonna be running any smoother
now oh I can zoom in quite a lot but
there is a device somewhere here there
we go wait no that's not it use a CCTV a
close attention to the deck sides okay
they're gonna help me navigate I'm still
gonna be lost I don't even know if this
is the right one that's cool
cool whoa
that's neat oh okay what's this do I
have another known mannequin Rita
there's not enough light man that's such
a weird concept that I have to get
ambient light to be able to look at this
CCTV has minimal rains one light or low
fuel two batteries need a flashlight
supplies and resources are limited use
sparingly follow signs find path to the
other side decade cool I can't go down
there it's been all bashed up I hope to
stop a monster and apparently there's
some sort of a quarantine around here oh
geez oh oh jeez I don't have a
flashlight oh gosh oh gosh no my man the
ship just farted alright let's drop down
why not because I feel like it
so apparently as is the namesake of the
game you are a stowaway on a ship and I
don't know why you decided to so I on
this particular ship that probably has a
loose
hey talking they're fine you all right
what else do we go let me read by the
light of this horrifying TV I saw the
doc escort someone on board today was
cleaning the deck that's three people
he's brought aboard now that I've seen
at least haven't seen the other two in a
while wonder if they're still here oh
they're still here all right they've
just been mutated to do a horrible
monstrosity man I am sad that I got to
this game whoa turn handle I didn't even
know there was a handle there I couldn't
see a goddamn thing
mouseup wait oh okay so let me check
mine oh there's nothing here well well
that's not good
turn hint no not that I'm not not
looking for that right now man I mean it
looks staying good I just wish it would
oh that's creepy
oh that's creepy looking at it I was too
busy looking at my how cool my lighter
was okay so I need to go the D deck but
there's something down here he can glean
bob and weave
man I'm sad that this Kickstarter didn't
go through it would have been a great
game one of the one of them has escaped
one of them great god damn it there's a
light here but again
ah Jesus gotta catch what happened my
lighter just went out good
oh that's one of them not good things I
barely read this hi hello hi friend how
are you doing are you gonna start
bobbing your head around like re 77 well
who's there no one okay so that's how
this games gonna be huh
right one of them has escaped i
barricaded what remains of the door to
protect the rest of the deck not sure
how long it'll last for I'm gonna head
down to B deck that guy in the diner
suit diver suit seems to hunt in the
upper decks it'll be safer oh sure I
left my flashlight down there you mean
down here where I is I wanna go down
there holy [ __ ] everything about that
stairwell screams that I'm gonna die all
right let's go for it
my lighters out of fuel I stupidly let
it run while I was watching it huh those
eyes oh I thought it was eyes I thought
that was eyes that's a little weird
that's what is that this room okay Oh
concerned about the breathing okay they
want some privacy they thought that I
was another person someone for an
intimate encounter on a deserted ship
but that ain't me oh is that a
flashlight that better be a flashlight
[ __ ]
yes glass-like too cool oh that ain't
good
the engine room hath doth been blasted
oh boy now I get to go back here oh boy
okay can I run I can run a little bit
it's more of us didn't scare me at all
I'm not scared by steam as is evident
from other horror games that I played in
the past steam does not bother me
doesn't bother me none oh this is open
now oh wait this is over before the last
note why do I need to read the last note
I mean these are all very useful
tutorials from my everyday life but I'm
not a presenter
okay alrighty then
or evening are you being chased by an
entire Orchestra oh look in the strings
now yeah this game looks good but it
doesn't run a hundred percent well
obviously it's an early access so it's
an early demo so it's not the full what
to expect out of the game I imagine okay
yeah okay yeah are that worked what is
with that why is that still on my feed
look at the goddamn door what's
happening okay so there's a toolbox in
there is that supposed to help me I
don't understand what you're funneling
about oh hello
did that change god I don't know idea
okay last note and thankfully it taught
me that turn this off those damn vents
upstairs always getting clogged if I
have to crawl through them one more time
remember to repair the vent cover at the
top of D deck stairs by the storage room
whoa so there's a vent that I canna go
through is what you're saying I got more
lighter fuel which is a good thing I
guess so there's a vent somewhere around
here then I'm gonna be able to crawl
through ok CCTV muttering so that's this
room I'm out of batteries already how
seasons we still got another lighter hey
guys stop wasting that but I have no
indication meter of when it's gonna be
out I open the nope just lose right to
the door no matter where I'm looking
okay so this is a toolbox that I saw my
sister
okay that's good I guess I don't know I
guess it's good oh okay scare me scare
me so d deck
wait storage oh it blasted off of that
oh [ __ ]
alright well I guess I'll go up here
then well this is spoopy don't mind me
oh my man poop in my pants but I'm
pretty sure this is the entrance to the
thing but I don't have enough I don't
have enough anything to be able to crawl
all the way through here without being
accosted by something oh there goes now
I'm in complete darkness to be able to
do that how am I looking at where's up I
can barely see
[Music]
the run I'm trying to help unless I am
the monster okay now that we got to
someplace where we can actually see man
I swear that's a bad sign okay boom did
I fall can't really tell Oh who's Adam
on this happen can't see anything I'm
out of flashlights and lighter okay
there I go I knew it okay is there
anything else over here that I need what
is this batteries thank you give me
those okay so I'm gonna be very sparing
with this and only when I need it not
immediately only when I need it
can I go down there boy okay so where
did that guy run through oh is this is
low this is blowed up
[Music]
I mean it crossed my mind maybe the
possibility of giving him unquestionable
freedom the pressures too damn I'm one
of these days it's gonna blow I wonder
how long this valve will regulate the
pressure captain won't listen oh well
not my problem what is what's making the
ruckus is this gonna blow when I twist
it it might blow oh that sounds like
it's gonna blow whoa hello holy [ __ ] hi
are you waving to me okay
probably shouldn't have stopped for that
is it gonna blow David there's got to be
something else to be done about this
right no no that's it I'm twisting in my
mouse every which way so I don't think
that's it there's got to be something
else no that's just the same thing that
it was shown before I guess there was
another way that I could go over
down here down seems good down seems
real good boy thank you for all the
tutorials I mean they honestly are very
helpful I just gotta figure out what I'm
supposed to be doing more lighter yes oh
this looks dark that's something no it's
just a slot for pooping okay I apologize
for what was probably one of my girliest
screams I thought she was right up my
butt whoever she was hi I should have
helped myself a little better together I
apologize I get new what is that a
lounge area she's watching you is she
now oh well does she like what she sees
probably not there I can go further down
though it's always a good sign oh that's
the same thing
ooh there I'll just take these thank you
spare everything but I don't even know
if they're gonna help can I open this no
I cannot okay going back up whoo all
right don't know why that keeps
happening like that oh this is ominous
did I come this way or am I going this
way I can't I can't quite tell oh oh
[ __ ]
dead end oh good and foggy good and
foggy there's nothing here
just a bunch of dead ends cuz I can't go
down that way to the right so I got to
go back up I apparently apparently so
that looks important okay but now which
one does this go - I'm not represent
sure it wasn't very obvious which one
goes where okay
it's that a bad thing should I go down
there way Hey okay you're why what is
that what is it wind
what's that leg up a Mongol outfit I
have no idea so weird okay so I'm gonna
town is that B this might be the CCTV
area
I totally is okay so why was this being
monitored and why is she watching me
good questions the diver is toying with
me he opened all the doors to the Med
Bay and let them all out he removed the
handle from the D deck doors leaving me
to fend for myself I found a spare
handle and while the locker rooms when I
get my strength back I'll make a break
for it
well okay it seems like you didn't make
it you're not okay after all so straight
down this way at the end of the hall
should be where I was supposed to go
right I just got okay there we go I was
about to say I just got batteries
wait a minute have I been here before
wait a minute I already know about the
lighter but have I been here before
what wait a minute did it did it send me
in a big circle I mean I'd be totally
fine if it did but oh okay so
ah here yes open what the [ __ ] was that
all about those weird okay it opened
instantaneously did I make it oh [ __ ]
okay well this doesn't seem like an exit
kind just seems like more death Oh
hmm that's not good
oh I thought that was a pile of bodies
at first okay oh geez oh geez scoop whoo
geez I can't read this it's too dark hey
what does that mean do I get a gold star
did I win did I win
I probably won that's probably what this
means I did so good that was on Mary
those footstep Estep swoon on me
okay so that's blocked off okay already
then okay they go that way has nothing
to do that way okay only one way here we
go
I guess I mean oh it's back to that one
then oh good I was hoping to see the
weird shadow
[Music]
that was so good dear
oh that was so good okay so I think
that's all for that one it is it's a
dang shame that the game wasn't funded
on Kickstarter that was a really well
made demo that was really interesting
and scary and I mean it wasn't optimized
perfectly obviously because he didn't
run quite well but even so it was a good
proof of concept it could have been
turned into something way bigger and
better I think with a slowdown was just
because the whole ship was in one level
and you were just wandering through the
same place it was a lot for the computer
to load but either way that's really
good I hope there's still some lingering
light left in this project because it
could be turned into something really
cool so I don't know I'll link to the
developer's website and all that stuff
so you can find out for yourselves but I
really like this game and I'm really sad
that I didn't get to it sooner so thank
you everybody so much for watching send
the developers some love in whatever way
you can and as always I will see you in
the next video bye